GOOD MORNING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR JUNE SIX
SIR BY CALLED ORDERS
PLEASE ADVISE AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING IF HE'S USING MADE
IS ALSO BEING TELL MADAM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO YEAH FLORA
GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE
MAIENSCHEIN HERE QUIRK SILVA
FROM LAST YEAR RIVAS YEAH WICKS
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND WE HAVE A CONCERN GENDER IS
OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
SECOND GOOD MOVE ACCOMMODATE
SECONDED BY MISTER RAMOS --
MATTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HI CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE I HAVE
NOT HEARD OF AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS
MATHIS I WORK CELL PHONE
FROM CHINA FROM US I RIVAS HI
RIVAS I WORKS HI WICKS
I'D CUNNINGHAM ON CONSENT
CUNNINGHAM I PAST
AND -- THIS RULES COMMITTEES
JERK THANK YOU VERY MUCH